cuando todavía podrían ser eliminados o justo antes de que se desarrollen?
Les diré cómo podría la miniaturización llevarnos hasta allí.
Aquí se ve el típico microscopio de laboratorio que usan los patólogos
para observar una muestra de tejido,
para una biopsia o una prueba de Papanicolaou.
Este microscopio que vale USD 7000
lo usa alguien con años de especialización para identificar células cancerosas.
Esta es una imagen enviada por una colega mía de la Universidad Rice,
Rebecca Richards-Kortum.
Ella y su equipo han miniaturizado
ese microscopio en 10 partes de USD 1
que cabe en el extremo de una fibra óptica
y esto significa que en lugar de tomar una muestra de un paciente
y enviarlo al microscopio,
podemos traer el microscopio al paciente.
y en lugar de esperar que un especialista analice las imágenes,
una máquina puede distinguir entre células normales y cancerosas.
Ahora bien, esto es importante
porque descubrieron al trabajar en comunidades rurales,
que incluso cuando se dispone de una unidad móvil de diagnóstico
que puede desplazarse para realizar pruebas,
juntar muestras y enviarlas a un hospital central para su análisis,
que días más tarde, las mujeres a quienes llamaron
-- si los resultados de las pruebas fueron negativos --
para pedirles que acudan al hospital,
la mitad no se presentó porque no pueden permitirse el viaje.
Con un microscopio integrado y el análisis por computador,
Rebecca y sus colegas pudieron equipar una unidad móvil
configurada para la detección y para tratamiento al mismo tiempo.
Eso significa que se puede hacer un diagnóstico y tratar a la vez
de modo que nadie quede sin tratamiento.
Esto es solo un ejemplo de cómo la miniaturización puede salvar vidas.
Como ingenieros, vemos esto como una simple miniaturización.
Se trata de una cosa grande hecha pequeña,
pero lo que les dije antes sobre las computadoras
es que transforman nuestras vidas
cuando son lo suficientemente pequeñas para llevarlas a todas partes.
Y ¿cuál es el equivalente de dicha transformación en el campo médico?
Bueno, ¿y si tuvieran un detector tan pequeño
que pudiera circular por dentro de su cuerpo,
encontrar el tumor por sí mismo
y enviar una señal al mundo exterior?
Suena un poco a ciencia ficción
pero, en realidad, la nanotecnología nos permite hacer precisamente eso.
La nanotecnología nos permite reducir las partes componentes de un detector
-- del grosor de un cabello humano, es decir, 100 micrones --
reducirlas mil veces, hasta los 100 nanómetros.
Y eso tiene profundas consecuencias.
Sabemos que a nanoescala, los materiales cambian sus propiedades.
Un material como el oro,
molido y transformado en polvo, en nanopartículas de oro,
cambia su color de dorado a rojo.
Un material más exótico como el seleniuro de cadmio
-- un cristal de gran tamaño y de color negro --
hace brillar sus nanocristales al ponerlos en un líquido y bajo una fuente de luz:
y se ve azul, verde, amarillo, naranja, rojo,
todo depende solo de su tamaño.
¡Es increíble!
¿Se imaginan un objeto similar en el mundo macro?
Es como si todos los vaqueros de algodón que tienen en su armario
pudieran cambiar de color solo por cambiar de talla.
(Risas)
Como médica, lo interesante para mí
es que no solo el color de los materiales es lo que cambia a nanoescala;
sino que la manera de viajar por el cuerpo también cambia.
Y esta es la observación que usaremos para mejorar la detección tumoral.
Les mostraré lo que quiero decir.
Este es un vaso sanguíneo rodeado por un tumor.
Inyectaremos nanopartículas en el vaso sanguíneo
para observar cómo pasan del sistema circulatorio al tumor
ya que muchos de los vasos sanguíneos rodeados por tumores presentan fugas
y las nanopartículas pueden filtrarse de la circulación sanguínea en el tumor.
La filtración depende de su tamaño.
Así pues, en esta imagen,
las partículas más pequeñas de color azul, de cientos de nanómetros, se filtran,
mientras que las mayores, de color rojo y de unos 500 nanómetros,
siguen atrapadas en el torrente sanguíneo.
Como ingeniera, esto significa
que el tamaño de un material que construyo
puede cambiar el lugar de su destino en el cuerpo.
Mi laboratorio diseñó recientemente un detector tumoral tan pequeño
que puede viajar dentro del cuerpo para detectar tumores.
Lo diseñamos para que oiga una invasión tumoral:
la orquesta de señales químicas
que los tumores necesitan producir para extenderse.
Para que un tumor rompa el tejido donde se forma,
tiene que producir químicos llamados enzimas
y con ellos abrirse paso a través de los tejidos.
Estas nanopartículas están diseñadas para ser activadas por estas enzimas.
Una enzima puede activar mil reacciones químicas en una hora.
Para un ingeniero, es una proporción de 1:1000,
o una forma de amplificación que hace algo ultrasensible.
Así que hicimos un detector ultrasensible al cáncer.
Pero ¿cómo hago que esta señal activada se transmita al mundo exterior,
donde puedo tomar medidas?
Para ello, usaremos una vez más la biología a nanoescala,
y esta vez tiene que ver con el riñón.
El riñón es un filtro.
Su función es filtrar la sangre y eliminar los residuos con la orina.
Resulta que lo que el riñón filtra
también depende del tamaño.
Así pues, en esta imagen, se puede ver
cómo todo por debajo de los 5 nanómetros
pasa de la sangre, a través del riñón, en la orina,
mientras que todo lo demás que es más grande, queda retenido.
Así que si hago un detector de cáncer de unos 100 nanómetros,
lo inyecto en el torrente sanguíneo,
para poder filtrarse en la tumor y activar las enzimas tumorales
de modo que liberarán una pequeña señal
lo suficientemente pequeña para ser filtrada por el riñón
y eliminada con la orina,
tendré una señal en el mundo exterior que puedo detectar.
No obstante hay un problema más.
Esta es una señal tan diminuta
que no sé cómo detectar.
Bueno, la señal es solo una molécula.
Son moléculas diseñadas por los ingenieros, completamente sintéticas,
así que podemos diseñarlas para que sean compatibles con nuestra herramientas.
Si queremos usar un instrumento muy sensible y lujoso
llamado espectrómetro de masas,
entonces diseñamos una molécula que tenga una masa única.
O tal vez queremos hacer algo más barato y portátil.
Entonces diseñamos moléculas que pueden atraparse en papel,
como una prueba de embarazo.
De hecho, hay todo un mundo de pruebas de papel disponibles
en lo que viene a llamarse el campo de diagnóstico en papel.
Muy bien, ¿a dónde nos lleva todo esto?
Lo que estoy a punto de decirles,
es un sueño para mí, después de una larga vida de investigación.
No puedo decir que sea una promesa;
es un sueño,
pero creo que todos tenemos que tener sueños para animarnos a seguir adelante,
incluso, y quizás sobre todo, los que investigan tumores.
Les diré lo que espero que pase con mi tecnología,
y que junto con mi equipo haremos todo lo posible
para hacer de esto una realidad.
Bien, aquí va:
sueño que un día,
en lugar de acudir a un centro de diagnóstico caro
para una colonoscopía, una mamografía o una prueba de Papanicolaou,
se pueda inyectar una vacuna, esperar una hora,
y hacerse un análisis de orina en una tira de papel.
Me imagino que esto incluso podría ocurrir
sin necesidad de una fuente de electricidad constante,
o un profesional médico presente.
Tal vez podrían estar disponibles
para conectarse con la ayuda de un teléfono inteligente.
Sé que esto es un sueño,
pero en el laboratorio esto ya funciona con los ratones,
y funciona mejor que los métodos existentes
para la detección de tumores pulmonares, y cánceres de colon y de ovario.
Y espero
que un día podamos detectar tumores en pacientes
-- antes de que pasen esos 10 años desde su aparición --
en cualquier lugar, en todo el mundo,
y que esto lleve a un tratamiento temprano
para poder salvar más vidas de las que podamos hoy en día,
con la detección disponible.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)